bonjour à tous en ce week-end de
vacances scolaires intéressons nous au
tourisme à l'avenir du tourisme en
bourgogne franche comté et
particulièrement en milieu rural avec à
l'horizon 2020 deux projets
d'implantation de center parcs aux roues
c'est en saône et loire et à poligny
dans le jura 400 logements en pleine
nature avec parc aquatique center parks
à quel prix c'est le débat de la voie
est libre ce samedi avec nous deux élus
des collectivités appelés à participer à
financer ce projet est porté par un
investisseur privé
fabien genêt d'abord vice président
divers droite du conseil départemental
de saône et loire chargé de
l'aménagement économique et numérique
des territoires bonjour à vous face à
vous jean claude lagrange bonjour
conseiller régional socialiste avec nous
également clément delacroix bonjour vous
représentez les jeunes agriculteurs du
jura pour vous situer et de la bourgogne
franche comté aussi plus généralement
pour vous situez vous êtes plutôt dans
les favorable au projet puis deux
opposants à ces centerparcs edith bonnem
bonjour donc je préside à l'association
accueil paysan bourgogne puis jacky
lièvre bonjour membres du collectif créé
à cette occasion le g du rousset plantes
aux décors center parcs c'est un concept
de vacances au vert avec des cottages en
pleine forêt un parc aquatique tropicale
une durée de séjour à la carte plutôt
court en général il en existe déjà cinq
en france en picardie en normandie en
lorraine dans le loir-et-cher en sologne
et dans la nièvre survient peu sur
l'histoire du projet jean claude
lagrange
quand le groupe pierre et vacances le
manifeste son intérêt pour la bourgogne
franche comté
les élus se disent d'emblée c'est une
aubaine les élus à l'époque se dit c'est
une aubaine peut-être parce que c'est un
projet qui est quelque part focalise
l'attention sur la région bourgogne et
sur l'autre région à l'époque franche
comté mais rien n'avait pas assez duré
région n'avaient pas fusionné elles ne
font plus qu'une voilà quelques jours
les choses peut-être pas forcément et à
l'époque étant conseiller régional de
bourgogne ce qui me vaut peut-être de
voir un peu plus
d'ancienneté sur ce dossier depuis
j'avais la compétence économique à
l'époque la région bourgogne s'est
positionné favorablement mais avec des
conditions qui se sont précisées à
l'issue du débat public
donc c'est un un soutien quelque part de
la région et d'une collectivité soutenu
aussi par d'autres collectivités
d'autres acteurs du monde économique
parce que c'était effectivement un focus
sur la région bourgogne sur un aspect
qui est quand même primordial pour la
région le tourisme avec des
implantations des fois qu'on n'a pas été
fait au hasard et plusieurs proposé sur
3 17
c'est cette opération remonte
effectivement bien avant 2012
même 2014 c'est devenu vraiment un un
enjeu on le voit bien de débats puisque
étant voisin de ce territoire du rousset
je faisais partie d'une collectivité
avec meute urbaine le creusot montceau
qui répondait aussi au cahier des
charges
je pense que quand on parle d'emploi
d'économie de développement peut-être
que les question peut se poser
c'était logique que les collectivités
locales territoriales se positionne sur
un projet comme celui là fabien je
venais aujourd'hui le département porte
ce projet le président andré accary l'a
mis dans ses priorités pour le
département c'est vraiment le
département qui est appelé également à
financer la rue y aura une quinzaine de
millions visiblement répartis entre les
deux collectivités à peu près à moitié
moitié
c'est effectivement une mobilisation des
collectivités publiques à kotor ii à
côté de l'investisseur privé
pierre et vacances qui propose le projet
et comme dans beaucoup d'autres projets
économiques qui veulent s'implanter sur
le territoire naturellement les
collectivités locales
que ce soit les communes et communautés
de communes le département la région
sont là pour épauler l'investisseur
privé pour intervenir à ses côtés dans
ce projet c'est un peu particulier
puisque effectivement pierre et vacances
installe les cottage donc les 400
cottage qui vont être réalisés et puis
pour les équipements publics avec en
particulier l'aqua mundo et bien l'écho
des parkas pratiques
le parc aquatique les collectivités
s'engagent dans une société d'économie
mixte et donc investir réalise cet
investissement est ensuite le loup à la
société à pierre et vacances et donc
effectivement c'est un investissement
des collectivités le département de la
saône-et-loire a prévu
d'investir 7 millions d'euros dans cette
société d'économie mixte la région
apportera 8 millions d'euros et avec ses
15 millions d'euros on va pouvoir aller
chercher des concours privé avec auprès
des banques et des obligations bancaires
pour arriver au financement des 66
millions d'euros du coût du parc
aquatique pour un budget global de 170
millions d'euros effectivement je pense
que il faut relativiser bien sûr les
chiffres puisque dans une période où
l'argent public est rare il faut le
justifier il faut justifier chaque euro
que nous investissons et bien cet
investissement de 7 millions pour la
collectivité départementale permet
d'avoir un investissement global de 170
millions dont il ya un effet levier qui
est très important pour l'économie
locale pour l'emploi et pour le
développement de notre activité
touristique de notre département
alors arguments vous contestez notamment
dans le collectif le jet du rousset ses
retombées
vous n'êtes pas convaincu qu'elles ont
vraiment nuire les deux retombée je
voudrais qu'on soit quand même plus
globale puisque quand on parle de la
région maintenant la région à 2 center
parcs sur les bras si je puis dire alors
poligny dans le lien à l'euro c'est en
saône et loire
ça me rendrait sur les chiffres qui ont
été dits ne se concentrait plus que sur
le routier donc il faut multiplier par
deux ce qui fait des sommes quand même
très considérable monsieur genève aussi
d'oublier les 10 millions que de réseaux
et de voirie etc qui sont mises à côté
et qui viennent s'ajouter aux 7 millions
que département compte mettre cache dans
la sphère dans la semaine la scène et
puis ajoutez à cela le fait qu' il y un
emprunt de pour le département une
vingtaine de millions pour les chiffres
aujourd'hui sont devenus flou du fait de
la fusion des régions et d'un projet qui
a évolué sans qu'on sache bien où il en
est aujourd'hui peut-être que ce n'est
pas bouclé et que ce n'est pas de tout à
fait déterminé mais en tout cas on est
dans des montants tout à fait important
au même moment où on entend la
l'antienne il ya plus de sous dans les
caisses etc
jean claude lagrange qui représente l la
région pour le co la grande région
désormais sk toujours de la place pour
ces deux projets ou est-ce que la fusion
opérée d'accord ça sortirait l'un des
deux je suis pas encore sûr de bien
évidemment de l'aboutissement du projet
puisque j'ai parlé des nouvelles
conditions qui sont effectivement liée à
la fusion des deux régions à une
nouvelle loi qui questionne aussi les
départements mais je pense que fabien
genêt vient déjà de répondre parce que
quelque part le jeu soutient ce projet
dépasse le simple impact financier
on parle de budget faut savoir quand
même qu'aujourd'hui le budget consolidé
de la région c'est 1 milliard 300
millions d'euros par an que budget
d'économies de 60 millions par an et que
là on n'est pas sur un domaine
d'intervention des collectivités par des
subventions pour voir en un moment comme
l'expliqué mon collègue sur une société
d'économie mixte
ça s'applique à ceux cet équipement de
loisir mais ça s'applique souvent dans
d'autres montages opérationnel
immobilier on est dans un montage public
privé ou le public est quelque part
majoritaire dans une scène mais très
minoritaire puisque c'est l'industriel
ou en l'occurrence pour pierre et
vacances qui prend le risque commercial
monsieur jamais pardon peut être
répondre à monsieur lire je n'ai pas
oublié de sommes effectivement on peut
répondre sur la totalité il ya cet
investissement de 7 millions d'euros qui
n'est donc pas une subvention
ça veut dire que à la fin du projet on
peut récupérer les actions et la mise
donc c'est un véritable investissement
que cet investissement permet
effectivement que la scène emprunte de
l'argent mais comme dans beaucoup de
projets privés ou publics et ensuite la
location et le prix payé par pierre et
vacances le loyer de 4 2 millions vient
permettre de rembourser finalement ses
emprunts en parallèle le département a
mobilisé une enveloppe maximum de 5
millions d'euros pour permettre à semble
d'aménagement de la route départementale
qui permet de desservir le site pour
soutenir également la commune de la
communauté de communes ou les syndicats
d'eau pour permettre l'acheminement des
réseaux mais comme on le fait tous les
jours que ce soit dans une commune dans
un département où effectivement chaque
fois qu'il y a
projets d'investissement naturellement
les collectivités amène les réseaux
publics jusqu'au droit de la par semaine
donc c'est un aménagement plus tout à
fait normal 75 à un débat public les
lieux et qu'il ya en ce moment des
études complémentaires le groupe pierre
et vacances
nous avons d'ailleurs un vecteur je
précise à venir dans ce débat ce n'était
pas possible aujourd'hui mais il suffit
évidemment ce qui se dit aussi tout au
long de ces mois
il y à des études complémentaires qui
ont été demandés sur la faisabilité du
projet il ya notamment cette prison en
question des réseaux parce que les
piscines à l'idée est de l'eau a déversé
il ya cet accès avec 700 véhicules
attendu les jours d'arrivée ou de départ
de dans les senteurs passe donc à tous
ces aménagements qui sont pris en compte
également
je crois que c'est là la position c
était la position du président accary
lorsqu'il était dans l'opposition avant
2015 c'est la position de la majorité
départementale aujourd'hui nous voulons
effectivement pour répondre à la
question de votre émission nous voulons
à tout prix se sentent deux repartent en
saône et loire mais pas à n'importe quel
prix
pas à n'importe quel prix et donc nous
sommes très attentifs à 122 question
bien sûr financière tout cela est
étudiée mais également environnementales
sur les conséquences que cela peut avoir
et je crois que le débat public auquel
on a participé a été un moment important
intéressant parce que ça a permis de
faire apparaître ensemble de questions
techniques qu'il faut vérifier
maintenant donc il ya quelques études
qui sont nécessaires que nous allons
mener jusqu'à l'été pour permettre à
pierre et vacances de prendre
définitivement sa décision effectivement
il ya sur les questions
environnementales
une petite tortue cistude qui
semble-t-il pourrait traverser la route
départementale dont john pye donc on va
faire une étude pour vérifier comment on
gère cette problématique mais là encore
ce sont des problématiques qu'on
rencontre très souvent lorsqu'on fait
des aménagements routiers donc des
solutions qu'on trouve à une question
sur internet de ko face aux doigts sur
internet sa féroce sur l'impact de
l'environnement sur les matières
premières utilisées pour la construction
sur les matériaux utilisés aussi sur la
dépense d'énergie lorsque le projet aura
vu le jour et sur ce côté travaux à
faire peut-être aussi au bout de 15 ans
contre le projet aura vécu est-ce qu'il
ya pas un impact véritable sur
l'environnement pose question
internautes
je crois que ça a été ça a été vu et de
toute façon aujourd'hui lorsqu'on veut
accueillir autant de monde
un projet comme cela il est évident que
les clients les consommateurs les
usagers sont très attentifs à ces
problématiques et il est de l'intérêt de
pierre et vacances d'investisseurs
privés de répondre à toutes les normes
environnementales le terme d'
investisseurs privés en fait pour
revenir pour que ce soit complètement
clair pour les téléspectateurs
ce que nous contestons sur le plan
économique il ya d'autres aspects
écologiques sociales démocratiques mais
sur le plan économique
pierre il faut bien que tout le monde
sache que pierre et vacances n'est pas
un sou dans ce projet quand vous parlez
de l'investisseur privé l'investisseur
privé il déclenche le projet il achète
le terrain très peu cher en particulier
à poligny extrêmement peu cher alors
qu'ils vont ensuite le construire et
qu'il prendra de la valeur
mais d'une manière générale ce sont les
collectivités publiques d'un côté pour
tout ce qui est équipements touristiques
qui finance à 100 % pierre vacances et
le vent sur plan et ensuite ne le
construira que si la région et le
département l'ont acheté et c'est la
même chose pour les bungalows quatre
cents bungalows qui sont vendus à des
institutionnels des compagnies
d'assurance et serra et puis quelques
particuliers mais ils ne sont pas
investisseurs et c'est une particularité
française je voulais écrire ce jeune est
dans un courrier à plein temps pourquoi
donc alors que très souvent l'allemagne
montait en est montrée en exemple pour
sa bonne gestion
et bien quand pire la cance veut
construire à center parcs en bavière
il va chercher son argent sur les
marchés financiers et vaches taper à la
porte des collectivités c'est une grosse
différence
en clair je voulais répondre et vous
donnera la parole à deux trois poumons
économiques financiers juridiques qui
pour l'instant est annoncée jeudi avec
la région bourgogne franche comté et sur
ces deux projets aujourd'hui a donné un
accord de principe qui doit tenir compte
aussi de ces conditions
environnementales économiques et quand
on parle justement économie quand on pas
de société d'économie mixte ont pas de
l'argent des collectivités en face il
faut aussi de l'argent privé plus sûre
et la caisse des dépôts des banques mais
je crois qu'il sera important peut-être
pour répondre à monsieur liège que
l'investisseur pierre et vacances soient
aussi
au capital de cette scène parce que
c'est ça je pense la meilleure garantie
qui prend le risque aussi à côté des
collectivités dans la part privée du
capital qui permet ensuite de lever des
emprunts et qui sera porté par cette
scène est remboursé par par pierre et
vacances
edit bonnet vous présidez l'association
accueil paysan bourgogne le tourisme
vert est ce que c'est pas une solution
seulement pour attirer des gens chez
nous et peut-être après laisser revenir
ailleurs que dans cette bulle propre
ical alors personnellement et enfin
notre association pense que ça n'est pas
une bonne solution pour attirer les sens
en bourgogne la bourgogne vous le savez
est une région de qui un tourisme de
passage qui répétait un tourisme de
passage et c'est vrai que ce que la la
politique touristique menée par le
constate le comité régional de tourisme
vise à essayer de faire de la bourgogne
une destination de séjour c'est à dire à
augmenter la durée moyenne de séjour des
touristes forêt guerre de troie nommé
par exemple à center parc c'est ce que
c'est pas mieux qu'une nuit en chambre
d'hôtes
alors c'est sûr que si on construit
center parcs en termes de statistiques
le nombre de nuits en bourgogne va
augmenter la durée moyenne de séjour va
augmenter mais la question c'est à qui
est ce que ça va profiter parce que ce
que je ce que nous pensons c'est que en
fait les touristes quand ils viennent à
center parc ne viennent pas en bourgogne
1 ils viennent un center parcs dire
qu'ils ne viennent pas pour découvrir la
bourgogne mais ils vont sortir à priori
de leur bulle
alain alors ça c'est une discussion
à voir évidemment on peut toujours dire
qu'ils vont sortir ou dire qu'ils ne
vont pas sortir bon l'expérience montre
tout de même que le public qui vient
dans ce type de structure vient là
précisément pour être tranquille
décompresser c'est une des catégories
relativement aisée qui sont des urbains
stressés qui viennent ici pour pour
décompresser je ne restait qu il viendra
ailleurs finalement et qui viennent ici
comme ils viendraient ailleurs donc
c'est le concept de center parcs et des
intérêts ça n'est pas la bourgogne
donc je ne pense pas que ça puisse
quelque part avoir un impact à ce niveau
là clément de la croix alors oui donc
l'intérêt bien pour les viticulteurs de
bourgogne franche comté
donc pour retracer un petit peu
l'historique de pourquoi les gens et
sculpteur soutiennent ce le projet
center passe elle pourra vous dire en
général des terres agricoles exploitées
par des promoteurs de l'aide contre
edimbourg et ben non parce que déjà le
bon déjà nous au départ on était
exactement comme nos amis les élus
politiques
on était organisée et syndicalement en
deux régions donc la bourgogne et la
franche comté avec deux projets sont
interpark bien distincts et donc c'est
vrai que nous collègues bourguignons se
sont mobilisés en faveur du center parcs
bien plus qu'en franche-comté la
franche-comté n'ayant pas prise de
position on va dire officiel c'est à
dire que ça fait des promesses vous a
dit que les gens vont venir vous voir
non ce que je voulais dire c'est que
voilà c'est la fusion donc maintenant
que le syndicat va être régionalisées au
niveau bourgogne france comté c'est tout
naturellement que les jeunes
agriculteurs de franche comté ont pris
part à l'engagement qu'ils avaient pris
les bourguignons de leur côté les art
qu'est ce qui vous séduit dans ce projet
alors c'est pour répondre à madame
madame bonnet donc le center parcs
on est effectivement en cours déjà il se
fera pas sur des terres agricoles et
leur assure des forêts des forêts qui
sans grande valeur des réseaux vont être
amenés à être exploités ou sodore donc à
la limite autant les valoriser ces
surfaces en développant un parent
touristique ensuite sur la partie mise
en avant par même bonnet sur le les
séjours est-ce que déjà tout le monde
n'est pas tous les jours
n'est pas contre le center parcs de ce
que j'ai pu voir que en bourgogne
notamment le réseau bienvenue à la ferme
et le réseau gîtes de france soutiennent
le projet alors qu'il pourrait penser
que ça relèvera des nuitées chose qui
pensent pas étonné qu'ils soutiennent le
projet alors concrètement ça veut dire
quoi que les gens vont venir vous voir
dans les fermes que vous allez venir
pour proposer les produits dans leurs
murs parfaitement le but c'est de dire
ok pour son appart à certaines
conditions
à condition que le center parcs offrent
aux gens qui vont venir sur center parcs
une vitrine dont justement nos produits
agricoles pour notre région
mettre en avant nos produits la hausse
et sur l'aspect ailleurs déjà dans les
autres ce qui se fait ailleurs je sais
pas mais c'est à nous de se mettre aux
côtés de pierre et vacances pour dire ok
on est d'accord mais il faut tous les
jours toutes les semaines ya un marché
de producteurs qu'on puisse mettre en
avant les produits régionaux qui a un
repas gastronomique avec des produits
locaux une fois par semaine que
l'approvisionnement
on parlait de l'approvisionnement plus
globale sur la totalité de ce qui va
être consommée si la viande qu'il avait
consommée à center parcs
c'est du poulet de bresse c'est de la
viande de charolaise abattus sur place
qui fait tourner nos abattoirs est mon
outil de production
ok la banque aux nôtres et qui leur a
tout à gagner et il y a eu dans le débat
public en atelier sur le petit portait
spécifiquement sur les rapports de
center parcs avec l'agriculture qui
était très intéressant on peut être
complètement surpris que le milieu
agricole tout particulièrement tout
autour du rousset se soit porté comme si
c'était l'eldorado
on a cédé 47 ans dans son annonce et on
a fait les cons
si la clientèle ce sont les bobos
parisiens admettons et pour venir voir
vous savez le
le charolais ses 600 mille bêtes par an
en admettant que tous les restaurants à
l'intérieur de center parcs tiennent
leurs promesses et achète dans les
environs immédiats
on a fait le calcul ça a été validé par
la commission du débat public se
seraient 250 bêtes
ce n'est absolument rien allez alors moi
je suis le coréen 250 bêtes par rapport
à 600000 excusez moi mais attendez une
chose je suis quand même aussi
complètement surpris que des gens qui
défendent d'agriculture de l'ain dans
les tablettes doivent se fier à une
multinationale du tourisme pour essayer
de promouvoir là aussi charolais qui est
quand même quelque chose qui est n'a pas
attendu pierre est la contrée pour
clément de la croix alors effectivement
pour tout aussi on n'a pas attendu
pierre et vacances pour pour développer
pour faire la promotion de nos produits
après je crois qu'on est quand même au
niveau agricole dans une situation où il
faut savoir faire feu de tout bois
ça fait peut-être 200 200 bêtes à
l'année consommée par center parcs
mais j'ai envie de dire les petits
ruisseaux font les grandes rivières et
ses 200 + 200 + 200 si demain on se
mobilise pour que dans notre
restauration collective hors domicile
sur nos départements la viande consommée
soit déjà de la viande locale
rajoutez à ça celle du center parcs etc
et si on arrive à quelque part à
valoriser le produit de plus en plus
dans la dans la restauration hors foyer
comme ça je veux dire voilà il ya un
moment donné ils font il faut le prendre
il faut pas ils font pas attendre de
voir l'exporter à l'étranger via caméra
tant que témoin on pourrait rire
je crois que personne n'essaie de faire
croire que pierre et vacances est la
plus grande entreprise agricole de
france n'en c'est à vous tous
effectivement un groupe qui fait du
tourisme et qui est là pour faire du
tourisme
alors si effectivement ça peut avoir des
conséquences positives sur un certain
nombre de domaines économiques c'est
très bien mais la priorité c'est
effectivement d'améliorer nos capacités
touristiques et c'est vrai
qu'aujourd'hui il y a une vraie
problématique parce que vous l'avez très
bien dit madame bonnet nous sommes
connus la bourgogne en particulier la
saône et loire pour être une destination
de passage ce week-end beaucoup de gens
qui vont passer sur l'a6 mais qui ne
s'arrêteront pas forcément en saône et
loire où seulement quelques heures et
l'idée c'est de bien pouvoir les faire
rester plus longtemps
week-end un week-end plus longs voire
une semaine et vous savez très bien que
sur l'ensemble des chambres que nous
avons en milieu rural c'est trois ou
quatre dernières années
la saône-et-loire a perdu 14 hôtels on a
perdu une capacité de 200 chambres parce
que effectivement c'est très compliqué
pour faire vivre ses capacités
hôtelières
est-ce qu'il ya pas la seule où est-ce
qu'on n'a pas une bonne offre à offrir
un diamant parce que il ya un problème
de clientèle
et puis de ce qu'on appelle la
saisonnalité c'est à dire que en pleine
saison on arrive à remplir les hôtels
mais hors saison c'est très compliqué de
faire venir des gens et l'avantagé c'est
pour ça qu'on s'est mobilisée
l'avantagent du center parcs c'est que
ça améliore grandement la capacité
hôtelière puisque aujourd'hui en saône
et loire on est environ une capacité de
700 mille nuitées en milieu rural et son
retard par cas avec un taux de
remplissage de 80 % apportera 630 mille
nuitées donc on va quasiment doubler
notre capacité et je disais remplissage
à 80 % sur 365 jours par an aujourd'hui
dans le gîte de monsieur lièvre
je ne suis pas sûr que tout au long de
l'année il est 80 % de remplissage alors
qu'effectivement l' avantage c'est qu'on
aura des touristes tout au long de
l'année et pour un savant deux
structures beaucoup moins rire la
collectivité mais les attendait la
collectivité a également aidé y compris
votre gîte monsieur lièvre donc l'argent
public est allait investir également
chez un privé et c'est très bien et je
crois qu'il ne faut pas opposer les deux
les deux systèmes et les clientèles ne
sont pas les mêmes les prix le prix de
votre week-end chez vous n'est pas le
même que celui à center parcs
il faut au contraire additionner les
clientèles additionner les potentialités
pour pouvoir développer des traitements
vous répondrais des bois mais oui non je
pense que c'est ce etc
c'est se tromper et est allé dans un
système qui dans d'autres domaines a
fait la preuve qu'il ne fonctionne pas
je veux dire que ça fait penser ce type
de tourisme à ce qu'on peut appeler des
du système intégré en agriculture parce
que si on regarde un petit peu de près
comment ça se passe ça veut dire que
finalement pierre et vacances apporte
son concept apporte son nom d'on va
apporter ces touristes forcément parce
que les gens sont attirés par le concept
de center parcs et en échange le
département et la collectivité c'est à
dire les contribuables à porte
l'investissement du matériel un petit
peu comme dans le domaine agricole on va
apporter un bâtiment d'élevage
on va apporter la main d'oeuvre et puis
le groupe agroalimentaire va fournir
alors la comparaison est malheureuse
mais là dans le cas il s'agit de poulet
et et il va et va apporter le matériel
pour enfin l'aliment pour endormir les
poulets on sait très bien que dans le
domaine agricole ce système actuellement
est complètement obsolète et que pierre
et vacances n'a pas vocation à être une
entreprise de philanthropie et que
forcément au bout d'un certain temps
l'investissement dont on attend qu'il
soit rentable est en tout cas on peut
pas prédire que ce sera que ce sera un
échec mais on peut en tout cas dire sans
se tromper que c'est quelque chose de
très risqué donc je ne pense pas que ce
type d'investissement est et pour le
coup puis il faut se poser la question
de savoir pourquoi les petits hôtels
ferment c'est parce que ces petits
hôtels ils ont complètement c'est à
cause de ce centre d'art qu'il n'existe
pas aujourd'hui l'argent qui est mis
l'argent important qui est investi dans
center parcs de façon riquet risqué
pardon pour l'instant c'est zéro hier
être pour l'instant c'est zéro il ya
aucun argent qui a été déboursé puisieux
de s'entendre aujourd'hui n'est pas de
plaire à l'as monaco les ranger son
meneur rogers vols touristiques en
bourgogne et développement économique
que center parcs a rassuré tout le monde
je vais faire face comme du tour de
france en mars
en matière d'aménagement du territoire
et ça concerne beaucoup de paix de pays
ruraux gers et plus de 40 millions que
la région et les départements les
collectivités et met en place pour
assurer des services
or c'est aussi bien du loisir c'est du
tourisme c'est des services publics
on n'a pas focaliser l'action des
collectivités sur un seul projet en
économie j'ai déjà évoqué 60 millions ce
sera du développement industriel
ça sera des infrastructures on a
l'impression que on veut opposer à un
type de tourisme à un autre moi je pose
la question en mai deux tournants que
vivre tout le monde te rejoindre et pour
qu'enfin il ya un inventaire et
partenaires dans le débat ce qui est
quand même assez éloquent c'était trois
chambres consulaires
ce qui n'est pas toujours le cas était
d'accord avec culture métier c'est à
dire que les artisans du bâtiment les
artisans locaux
on se bat tous pour que des jeunes à
rester sur le territoire qu'on développe
l'artisanat local et là on a une
opportunité qu'on voudrait refusé ce
soit 500 sera face à des entreprises
location il peut y avoir effectivement
le protocole que j'évoquais que l'ici et
que les collectivités j'ai aussi nié il
sera très exigeant pourquoi on ne croit
pas sur l'exigence en matière de
l'environnement en matière économique en
matière de construction d'apport pour
les ressources locales
je dis pourquoi pas nous croire c'est
une vraie exigence qui revenu du débat
lancé par les collectivités
du coup on est dans un phénomène
similaire
lorsqu'on a soutenu l'installation de la
grande distribution et où détriment de
tout ce qui faisait vivre les
territoires les petits commerces la vie
locale et on concentre on met le paquet
sur un endroit donné
avec x millions et puis derrière les
gens souffrent et dépérissent
et ce qui s'est passé avec le petit
commerce c'est ce qu'on se propose de
refaire avec le tourisme en disant voilà
c'est une solution de facilité pour moi
de alors que les petits hôtels qui ont
des difficultés et bien il faut
peut-être les soutenir mais pas
uniquement un ici dans le charolais mais
dans toute la bourgogne puisque toute la
bourgogne finances dans tous les sens
des lois
or aujourd'hui qu'est ce qui se passe au
point de vue des agences du tourisme et
bien je crois vous êtes parfaitement au
courant
elle est menacée de diminution de ses
activités et de licenciement le center
parcs commence déjà à faire des victimes
dans le monde du tourisme avant d'être
sonné c'est bien c'est bien vrai et il
écume collatéral si j'aimerais qu'elle
ait des licenciements envisagés pour l'
agence de tourisme
mais un certain mental monsieur lire
restons restant réaliste et n'allons pas
convoquer des arguments qui n'ont pas
lieu d'être sur le sur le tourisme sur
l' agence départementale du tourisme
effectivement il ya une volonté de faire
en sorte qu'elle soit plus efficace
parce qu'aujourd'hui elle consacre 80 %
de son budget à du fonctionnement de la
gestion et seulement 20% à des actions
pour promouvoir le tourisme est
effectivement la nouvelle majorité
départementale a souhaité qu' on puisse
ramener ce ratio à 55 ans c'est à dire
qu'on fasse des efforts sur la gestion
pour pouvoir consacrer la moitié du
budget at de la communication de la
promotion pour faire venir des touristes
en saône et loire pour faire venir des
touristes dans l'egypte ou dans les
accueils à la ferme pour promouvoir
c'est différent tu travailles pas s'y
faire c'est évidemment pour communiquer
avant dans notre agence départementale
l'évolution avait fait qu ont consacré
beaucoup d'argent à la gestion de cette
structure et pas assez à la promotion
donc on améliore simplement les choses
avec cette fermer les robinets
c'est ce que vraiment il ya eu
simplement vous savez l'argent qu'ils
étaient dépensés pour la marque dont
tout le monde a oublié le nom qui a été
supprimée sinon la subvention est
maintenu moi je crois qu'il faut il faut
rappeler que sur le tourisme
il faut vraiment passer une économie
touristique aujourd'hui et donc il faut
professionnaliser les choses il faut
accompagner les professionnels du
secteur
et lorsqu'il ya une possibilité
d'investissement aussi important je
crois qu'il faut être aux côtés de celle
ci et je le répète les investissements
les investissements du département sont
sous sa seule son portable par le budget
département nous en reparlerons à la
deuxième partie de cette émission sur le
tourisme en milieu rural juste après le
journal de midi présenté par un liseré g
a tout de suite